[Musik]
Shalom Salaam auf Todeswunsch werden in
Israel für K jetzt CTR und Wasser hier in
Tel Aviv starten sie Israel abhängig
davon CL VG gefeuert dr.  Heilig Island soll den
spartanischen israelischen Palästina Enza
am Ball
Alon abschlagen, um an anderen zu arbeiten, die
Dr. passiert zu sein scheinen.  shalba Christus, es wird
mich Dämon zur Unterdrückung entzünden, nicht bevor
eine Illusion es fast behandschuht Austin
betoid Beispiel, wenn Stella
zwischen der Mission hier in Ramallah in
Annas Punkt Hollister Radames
kayamat Damaskus fabula angestellt ist, nicht in
einem wichtigen und so viel Nevison treffen
die schlauen
diese sind konflikt treffen und erwähnte
die hier Laden schikanieren das wort stein
disparitäten mo's oder geschoben es sogar
geholfen die Hoff mittag der eisernen kompromiss
UTC froschmänner geräumig meetha meetha preis
kokon ist beziehung jela fast alle
studien neigen zur vernunft sie können nicht wir
kommen  und unter der Navy stand staunend in
der zweiten freiheit baby go ist also
haus geworden
danke yeah sip gesichert a fängt
an los is israel ist das spazzy und
geht gut ja es liegt daran das ich alt genug bin mich
zu erinnern was hier
vor israel existierte  und es war kein Paradies,
was hier existierte, bevor Israel kein
Paradies war, weder für die palästinensischen Araber
noch für die Juden, es war eine geteilte
Konföderation von Turin  licted land ist dies jetzt nicht gelöst,
aber zumindest gibt es eine bestimmte
Aurazone, die für mein Volk
für das jüdische Volk seit Tausenden von
Jahren nicht existiert hat
In Palästina
töteten Axtmänner das Eisen einen Geistlichen, der ein außerirdischer
Palästinenser
ist
Es ist das einzige
Heimatland der israelischen Juden, die
palästinensischen Araber haben kein anderes Land,
das sie als Volk ihr Zuhause nennen können, und
das Gleiche gilt für die israelischen Juden, sie
haben kein anderes Land, das
acht Menschen hat, die sie jetzt, glaube ich, ihr Zuhause nennen können
dass es keine Perspektive einer
sofortigen Vereinigung zwischen
Palästinensern und Israelis gibt, ist
es unrealistisch, Gemeinschaften zu erwarten,
die in Blutvergießen, Wut,
Hass, Gewalt versunken sind  o
nach 100 Jahren plötzlich zusammen in ein Flitterwochenbett zu springen
und anzufangen, Liebe zu machen, nicht Krieg, das
funktioniert einfach nicht so, was wir brauchen,
ist, dieses kleine Land in zwei
noch kleinere Wohnungen aufzuteilen,
eine für die Israelis, eine für die
Palästinenser in friedlicher
Koexistenz und  Keine Gewalt, siehe
Pleadians Darks Items, ekstatisch,
Überschreitung, ich bin wütend, ein paar Ziffern von I
fange an, jedes Fragment zu verlieren, ist
noch ein Realist, an diesem Tag sehe ich
dich, Baba, als einer der alarmierten Fuhrleute
aus Israel Sitas Ehemann Flick
und Tipi in Westernland East kochte  wie
wir es hier haben sollten, ist idealerweise Ihre Bar.
Ich bin nicht für eine Zwei-Staaten-Lösung. Ich bin
nicht für eine Ein-Staaten-Lösung. Ich bin
für eine Welt ohne Nationalstaaten
ein Ort, an dem
sie alles nennen
und fühlen können, ja, es ist machbar,
kompliziert, aber machbar, weil es in
diesem Land sehr unterschiedliche
Gebiete gibt, in denen überwiegend
palästinensische Araber leben, andere Gebiete  s, die
überwiegend israelisch-jüdisch sind, und es
gibt einige gemischte Gebiete, was wir brauchen, um
eine Grenze zu ziehen, es wird palästinensische
Araber im zukünftigen Staat Israel geben,
es wird wahrscheinlich einige israelische Juden
im zukünftigen Staat Palästina geben, aber
jedes dieser Völker  eine Wohnung brauchen,
einen Ort, den sie
ihr Eigen nennen können und nicht als Minderheit behandelt werden
, wissen Sie, da Asante Zardoz nicht die
meisten ein Ausgangsschild über ein noch ein
anderes Zeichen sein und eine unter
- Alicia Perez muslimische Debatte in Tainan
sehen  Amnon-Labor Er führt einmal in Angst Elta eine Farm ein.
Das ist lange. Hat
er einen Artikel in diesem Land
? Medien von Thomas Neues Jahr seit einer
Quinta-Linie Mandarin, als der Koalitions-
Eisenberg auf dem Hamish-Häuptling
bei Erwähnung ultra erschüttert wurde  Veteran Tom Bearden
CN Twitter Visier auf Drive
was trägt er ein ängstlicher ein Kompromissverlierer
Vishton tut MacDonald im Weltraum auf der
Überweisung nicht
gut für Israel Ich kann das nicht verallgemeinern, weil
Israelis genauso unterschiedlich sind wie Pa  Lestinianer
tiefer gibt es überall gemäßigte extremistische
Fanatiker
und leider
wächst der ISM für Neulinge in den letzten Jahren unter
Israelis, er wächst unter
Palästinensern und anderen Muslimen, er
wächst in der christlichen Welt, er
wächst in Europa, es gibt einen universellen
Anstieg des Fanatismus, aber ich sehe  keine
Alternative zu einem Kompromiss zwischen
Israel und Palästina,
nur weil keine der Parteien
verschwinden wird keine der Parteien
von hier weggehen wird sie können kein
glückliches Paar werden sie müssen
Nachbarn
werden  Sharon, wir hatten stoisch im
Fagin-Versteck für einen Startbildschirm, Don,
entschied, diese Villa Rises
[Music]
for your Carpathia, warf einen Blick auf den ersten
funa funa halong-Körper von Abijah, Hilfe in
der Tyldus oz-Miliz, Peitschen auf
Straftäter
Gericht besser auf
alle Patienten EMA-Mitarbeiter, die sie
in einem Austin auf Azeroth anziehen wollen, wurden
Frankish zu einem verletzten Austi  n
Anatolians Zoo Median Grob Tante Ida's
Hartigan Zillionen von Dendy Bannon Lautely
Stefan ein Heel Toe Post Bataillone Eintrag, den
sie debattierte, wechselte den Mittelsmann
Temporization Golf Palästina Jordanien
OT Hawk Suzette's Lycia heute Britischer
Außenminister Arthur James Balfour
Rainfarn Ehrlichkeit ein Opfer und ein National
und ich'  m geschichtet als Rhodesien Falk in
Palästina ein Zoo im Land auch Verzweiflung
Heights Pavitra vom palästinensischen Muslim
und die Kristen am
Grenznachrichtensender Ziegland
D Oktan Nachmittag Punkt Zip siehe g'yahhhh
ein ungültiges verleumdetes Ergebnis in Fulton D
Knurren - apokalyptische Vibration und
endogene Innovationseinheit  universeller
isthmus vorhang so annum und klebe den
eurasischen in van daan
von shaun deeb wenig ricky auf dem sofa
hinden pflicht nach palästinenser sind
fazool unter sofa hindern das camp's
gewonnen nervig ziegler als oval/tante
katie krass und es ist jana station top
mahagoni auf der agora
hat nicht gebissen
1900 Z nichts gegen das Böse ist Krankenhaus
Ian - exogener Mand  ates kibbuz de uno
traf sich aus den USA um
noch auf jenen Bush verlorenen leichten
Dämmerungsschlag nach Thailand auf einer
Ergänzung zu einem ANOVA Bayesianischen Start
Sous-Chef-Clan der Wüsteninseln Wasser aus
ihrem eigenen Alpha Zamboanga Nam, aber
oft einfach Hemmung  oben
Khalid ist Ammoniak und ein Plan sehr
verstreut unter Gleichrichter Komma
Sartain dann suji Nazis vahana
Palästinenser auf oder EEMA in Demi verstecken sich auf
Vietnam Signalbild Afrika der angrenzende
offene Durchflussregler namens Clifton ein
Hobby-Rollladenventilator die s und die Palästinenser
sind Boden MIT ihnen Burger Creek  Unfit
schickte neun Onsen Hundert oft gefülltes
Sesh-Riff David Ben Gurion in Amandas
Vorbehaltsversion gabelt sehr glatt die
Unpanik-itis, die Sie essen, und Statushaus als
Nama-Vitamin-E-Öl,
ja, Israels abscheuliche Höhen und dies
ist ein Meter schwerer Haydens
nach salzigem Testament  Jakob, sie
saugen zum Gelübde auf,
das ist eine große Umarmung nach dem salzigen
testamentarischen Stein, der barmherzig bewertet, F
ein Segen,
gut mein relatio  n zum Alten Testament sind
keine religiösen Beziehungen Ich bin keine
religiöse Person und in einer religiösen
Person, aber historisch wurde mir klar, dass
das jüdische Volk als Volk nie
eine andere Heimat hatte, als Individuen
manchmal ja als Volk nein jetzt in einer
Welt  der Selbstbestimmung ist es nur
fair, dass das jüdische Volk
das Recht hat, selbst auf einem sehr kleinen Stück Land die Mehrheit zu sein,
nicht eine ewige
Minderheit, manchmal gut behandelte Minderheit,
manchmal verfolgte Minderheit, sondern immer
eine Minderheit.
Ich denke, die Juden hatten ein Recht darauf  eine
Mehrheit in einem kleinen Stück Land sein und
das einzige Land, in dem sie jemals
eine Mehrheit waren, das einzige Land, das sie jemals
Heimat nennen, ist dieses Land. Mir wurde klar,
dass dieses Land nicht leer ist und dass meine Eltern nicht leer sind,
als sie aus Europa geworfen wurden
in den 1930er Jahren und als sie hierher kamen
, kamen sie nicht in ein leeres
Land, die Palästinenser waren hier und
sie hatten das Recht, hier zu sein, und sie
hatten das Recht, dieses Land für sich zu beanspruchen
Heimat, aber es gibt genug Platz,
da diese Kreuzung darauf existierte,
würden Sie nicht antworten, dies ist eine Verneinung über
den Stamm, von dem Sie sprachen, sind auf Insulin.
Kings Hebron passt oft, fühlt sich effizient an
kann in einem Film gewinnen,
ist die weiche, intelligente Waha Missus, na ja,
es ist die Natur von Träumen, es ist
nicht die Natur des Zionismus oder die Natur
einer erotischen Fantasie oder die Natur
einer Fantasie über das Reisen in ein
exotisches Land,
jede Erfüllung ist niemals  So wunderbar
wie der ursprüngliche Traum,
das gilt universell für jeden Traum,
selbst wenn Sie dieses Interview geplant oder davon geträumt
haben, haben Sie richtig von
etwas Idealem geträumt, es wird nicht
ideal.
Ich hoffe, es wird gut, aber nicht
ideal. Israel ist ein wahr gewordener Traum  stimmt
und als solches konnte es den
höchsten Erwartungen der
Gründerväter und -mütter nicht gerecht werden, es gibt keine
Möglichkeit, einen Traum vollständig zu erfüllen,
nicht in der Literatur und nicht im Alltag
Leben und nicht im materiellen Leben und nicht im
Sex, ja, das ist sein Geld. Das Gefühl ist
genauso hoch. Legal und
geruchlos  spielen eine wachsende Rolle
und ich bin nicht sehr glücklich darüber, weil
ich im Grunde keinen Grund für einen
religiösen Konflikt zwischen gezeichnet und
muslimisch gesehen habe und Christen meistens auf Christen trafen.
Ich denke, verschiedene Menschen können
an unterschiedliche Dinge glauben, die sie vielleicht
sogar behandeln  dasselbe Land oder dieselbe
Stadt aus verschiedenen Gründen als heiliger Ort,
und jeder kann es auf seine Weise waschen und auf
seine Weise beten, es besteht keine Notwendigkeit
, einen religiösen Glauben zu untermauern, indem man
eine Flagge schwenkt, diese Idee, die zuerst
von den Dschihadisten und dann von den Dschihadisten erprobt wurde
Kreuzritter Ich habe nie geglaubt, dass
man nur seine Flagge darüber schwenken muss, um einen heiligen Ort
zu errichten, aber das
ist kein religiöser Konflikt, das ist ein
Immobilienkonflikt, im Grunde die
palästinensische Klasse  zielen darauf ab, dass dies ihr
Land ist, und sie haben Recht, die israelischen Juden
behaupten, dass dies ihr Land ist, und sie
haben auch Recht, und die Lösung ist ein
Kompromiss, und ich bin ein großer Anhänger von
Kompromissanalysen, die uns von Gott
eine wählerische Insel nennen
die schwinggeschwindigkeit der reliquieneinheiten in
halle halle bitumen denke du weißt
wenn religiöse menschen zu mir kommen ob
sie jüdisch oder muslimisch sind und sie sagen
gott hat uns dieses land versprochen meine
einfache antwort ist gott versprochen lass gott
sein versprechen erfüllen es geht dich nichts an
um Gottes Verheißung zu erfüllen suche
demütig und warte darauf, dass Gott seine
Verheißungen erfüllt wäre ich ein religiöser Mensch
würde ich sagen es liegt nicht an mir
er nimmt er gibt ich muss kein
religiöser Mensch sein ich glaube zufällig an
die Notwendigkeit des Andersseins  Menschen mit unterschiedlichen
Gesichtern, unterschiedlichen Hintergründen, um
durch schmerzhafte Kompromisse
zusammenzuleben  Das, was Sie wissen, ist Kacke, Höhle, Fleisch essen,
Sargon sehen, und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe es auswendig übersprungen,
und von der Erwähnung der Insel Suhana
Loserman auf der Emmanuel Lewis,
alle unter einem Erbstück, Feind, ungenäht
und Räude, sie sind sortiert genug. Ich bin
verärgert, Losin Art Abba  site van Easter
so caps by in vans Amal after the ocean
of air lockered Fluency and toystore a
bomb one beruhigte uns na ja, als ich ein
kleiner Junge war, war ich genauso fanatisch wie jeder
andere junge Israeli, mehr oder weniger, weil
ich an ein schwarzes und glaube  Weiße Welt,
gute Jungs, böse Jungs und für mich,
als ich sieben oder acht Jahre alt war,
waren wir die Guten und unsere
Gegner die
Bösen  Erfahrungen, um zu erkennen,
dass es in manchen Konflikten in manchen
Konflikten nicht nur um Schwarz und
Weiß geht, obwohl
jeder Konflikt auf der Welt Hollywood ist,
mit Guten und Bösen, manche
Konflikte wie der israelisch-palästinensische
Konflikte sind Tragödien im griechischen
Sinne der Welttragödie, die einen
Zusammenstoß zwischen richtig und richtig bedeuten,
manchmal wird es zu einem Zusammenstoß zwischen
falsch und falsch, aber die Geschichte von Israel
und Palästina ist keine Schwarz-Weiß-
Geschichte, sie ist nicht wie die Apartheid  nicht
wie Kolonialismus, es sagt, es ist nicht wie
Nazismus oder Faschismus, es ist ein tragischer Zusammenstoß
zwischen zwei sehr mächtigen, sehr
überzeugenden, sehr echten Ansprüchen auf
dasselbe Land, was schmerzhaft ist und
nur durch Kompromisse oder durch
Kampf bis zum Tod gelöst werden kann  Ich
bevorzuge einen Kompromiss darin, Bowie durch
Eitelkeit zu kennen, glatte Schreibers ESI und
unerschütterliche dikanka eindeutige Landenge auf
fanatischem Valentin, dem
Hausarzt, zuzuweisen, da die Amerikaner, die er wütend gemacht hatte, den
stierfressenden Präsidenten vermeiden
Die
Quellen sind nicht da draußen, sie sind
in fast jedem von uns.
Ich denke, Fanatismus ist ein schlechtes Gen in
fast jedem Menschen und
Fanatismus ist es sehr oft  manifestiert sich in dem Drang
, andere Menschen zu ihrem eigenen Wohl zu verändern
, wissen Sie besser als Ihr Ehepartner oder
besser als Ihr Kind oder besser
als Ihre Avenue-Geschwister oder besser als Ihr Nachbar,
was hier gut ist, was gut für ihn ist.
Sie fangen an, ihnen zu sagen, dass sie dies
ändern müssen  ist sehr nett, Sie können es
ihnen sagen, aber wenn Sie ihnen nicht sagen,
dass sie sich ändern müssen, wenn Sie
ihnen die Arme verdrehen, damit sie
die Art und Weise ändern, wie Sie denken, dass sie sich ändern müssen,
dann sind Sie ein Fanatiker, wenn Sie
ihnen sagen, entweder Sie  Ändere oder ich töte dich,
dann bist du ein Fanatiker und die Welt ist
voll von Menschen, die
den Drang militant verfolgen, andere Menschen zu
ihrem eigenen Wohl zu ändern, aber sie auf deine Art zu ändern
,
das ist Niclas Inter-Service ist argick
the Abszisse Interest an Agouti  Verwalten Sie
den Ironiker von Busan hinter uns.
Veröffentlichen Sie Inter gesendet und erweitern Sie die
Gründung. Erweitern Sie die Saison im Tourismus
ed ist ein schmidt wir würden dich
entweder nicht sehen wenn du - magana IDI
mm-hmm ja naja erstens
ist da dieser infantile drang, alle
werden gleich die anderen müssen
augen und ohren aufmachen sie müssen sich ändern
und  sei wie ich und dann wird
alles gut, denn ich bin perfekt und sie
sind es nicht außerdem ist der Fanatiker sehr
oft ein großer Altruist er
interessiert sich nicht für sich selbst er interessiert sich für
dich er will deine Seele retten wenn du dich
als unwiederbringlich erweisen kannst ist es unmöglich
Um deine Seele zu retten, wird er dich
zu deinem eigenen Besten erwürgen, aber er ist immer
an dir interessiert, das ist ein sehr
gefährliches Syndrom, weil er sich nicht
für dich interessiert, wie du es bist, er
interessiert sich dafür, was gut für dich ist, und
er weiß es besser als du  was
gut für dich ist, wenn du Raucher bist, wird er
versuchen, dich auf die eine oder andere Weise zum Nichtraucher zu machen
und wenn nicht Kreuzzug j
ihad Inquisitionsverfolgung als heiliger Geist
in' und die Angst stimmt schon so schick,
wenn du deine Eitelkeiten magst, mas hier
jetzt gut Angst und Wut sind der Treibstoff.
Sehr oft kämpfen wir gegen jemanden oder etwas,
weil wir es nicht wissen und wir nicht wissen.
Wir wollen es nicht wissen Wir haben Angst davor Wir
haben nicht nur Angst davor, was es
mit uns machen könnte Wir haben Angst davor, beeinflusst zu werden
Wir haben Angst davor, dass die Konfrontation mit
anderen unsere Gewohnheiten oder
unsere Perspektiven ändern könnte
Perspektiven mögen unsere Perspektiven
wir mögen unsere Denkweise, aber ich
glaube, es gibt gewisse leere
Zweifel am Fanatismus. Einer davon ist der Sinn für
Humor. Ich habe noch nie einen Fanatiker mit
Sinn für Sie gesehen
Humor
zu einem fanatischen Sinn für Humor zu werden, ist die
Fähigkeit, über sich selbst zu lachen. Manchmal
die Fähigkeit, sich selbst so zu sehen, wie
andere einen sehen. Dies ist ein sehr wichtiger
Hinweis aus Gründen von Jesus Christus. Halten Sie
die andere
Wange hin  wie ein Teppich unter
den Füßen des anderen nicht nur die Notwendigkeit
zu erkennen, dass es mehr als nur
eine Sichtweise gibt, mehr als nur eine
Perspektive und in manchen Fällen können beide
Geburtstagsperspektiven gültig sein, auch
wenn sie sich
wie die Israelis widersprechen  und die Palästinenser
kontaminieren Augmenter, die eine
Perspektive und offene Arme für einen nebligen
heiligen Geist wollen, kann Amanda nicht schälen und die
Frisur auf Tizen-Fanatikerin ein endloses
Jahr in Pilates-Massagezeit der Dämon
Anyhoo Appell in ins verschwunden so viel
getan werden tut er Sie  wird einen
Latissimus entwickeln, manchmal denke ich, wenn
ich Sinn für Humor in
Kapseln komprimieren und die gesamte Bevölkerung dazu bringen könnte,
meine Humorkapseln zu schlucken und die
Welt einer anderen Zone zu immunisieren, würde ich einen
Nobelpreis für Medizin verdienen, nicht für
Literatur, aber lassen Sie uns sagen, warten Sie  einen Moment,
was versuchst du zu tun, andere Leute dazu zu bringen,
deine Humorkapseln zu
ihrem eigenen Wohl zu schlucken, du willst sie ändern,
du willst sie dazu bringen, dich selbst zu mögen, so
y  Sie können es fangen, während Sie dagegen kämpfen.
Fanatismus ist sehr kontaminierend. Ja,
ich habe anti-fanatische Fanatiker und
Punk in der US-Armee gesehen. Wir haben Nets-Feeder.
Ankush Bohan war so wütende Worte auf
diesem Telefon. Künstler müssen ein unbedeutender
Dinosaurier sein. Hey Steve Falen Tag für
Sharons Handwerk  und das hält ihn in
Hanoi in Si-Bandana-Knechtschaft in einer stattlichen
Position
Es ist viel einfacher, die
Faust in die Luft zu schütteln und zu schreien, dass diese
Menschen vernichtet werden müssen, aber manchmal,
wenn man sich das vorstellen muss, wenn man
sich tatsächlich vorstellen muss, wie man
ein fünfjähriges Mädchen erwürgt, wird es plötzlich
sehr schwierig, leichter zu sagen, dass
sie vernichtet werden
müssen  sie sind der abschaum der erde sie sind
eine bedrohung sie sind ein problem
sie einzeln zu betrachten hier glaube ich
sehr an neugier
hier bin ich großartig  Glaube an
Neugier als ein weiterer Anti-Hund gegen Fanatismus Ich
denke, eine neugierige Person ist eine Person,
die sich oder sich selbst manchmal die
einfache Frage stellt, was wäre, wenn ich hier wäre, was wäre,
wenn ich er wäre, was wäre, wenn ich Muskeln aus
Israel gewesen wäre, ein palästinensischer
Junge gewesen wäre  Männer, ich stelle mir diese Frage nicht,
weil ich mich komplett
mit meinem Gegenüber oder meinem Feind identifizieren möchte, nein, ich
möchte einfach die Komplexität der
Situation sehen und ich glaube, dass Menschen,
die sich die anderen vorstellen können, Menschen, die
neugierig genug sind, sich die anderen vorzustellen
werden bessere Ehepartner, bessere Eltern sein
und wenn dieses Interview spät
genug am Abend präsentiert wird, werde ich Ihnen sagen,
dass neugierige Menschen noch bessere
Liebhaber sind als Menschen, die es nicht sind, da
es keine Ahnung ist, dass der Künstler le chiffres
antworten würde, wenn wir Trailer sehen könnten  Eine Sünderin
wie diese eine Kunst in der Schule Alessandra
Saluton Buted Analphabetin oder Physiotherapeutin
Hannigan schickte Holly Holly unanständige
Agenda kommt in Mode
und Pattaya Village wechselt ihren Prozess  Freiheit
Freiheit gut du weißt zu sagen, dass
sie eine zentrale Rolle spielt, wäre eine
Untertreibung
Leben, auch wenn ich nicht danach strebe, zu
sitzen und zu schreiben Ich beobachte Menschen Ich
spioniere Fremde aus Ich versuche herauszufinden, was
ihre Geschichten sein könnten
Du kennst Literatur und  klatsch sind
cousins sie sind sich sehr ähnlich sie entstehen beide aus n
ugier, aber es gibt einen unter
chied klatsch ist der drang ins f
nster des nachbarn zu schauen was d
los ist literatur gibt dir e
was besseres als dass sie d
r die chance gibt die welt zu sehen
durch das Fenster des Nachbarn
gibt es dir sogar die Möglichkeit, im
Fenster des Nachbarn zu stehen und
dich selbst zu betrachten, wie du aus dem
Fenster des Nachbarn schaust. Ich denke, es ist ein
wunderbares Geschenk, das dir die Literatur
geben kann, die dir das Herz geben kann, die dir die Neugier
geben kann  Lernen Sie die Geschichte, die grundlegende
Enden in einer Stunde verbrennt, sehen Sie sich selbst in Damon's
selbst
an  icraft,
das beeinträchtigt unseren Zustand, hallo Dennis,
Kompromisse eines Kerls, erwähnte Gaddafi,
fanatisch und sehr fanatisch in östlichen
Unternehmen. Nachahmung von Vermessungsschiffen
nur ein
Scherz - tut mir leid wie ein Eisteekuchen in
Connecticut, da wir stolz und kompromissbereit waren, fühlten wir uns
fest, es wird die Höhe
überschreiten - Kompromisse, die Sie kennen, nicht nur die
Fanatiker, viele junge Idealisten glauben,
dass Kompromisse hässlich
sind
Wortschatz Das Wort
Kompromiss ist gleichbedeutend mit dem Wort
Leben Das Gegenteil von Kompromiss ist nicht
Idealismus und Hingabe Das Gegenteil von
Kompromiss ist Fanatismus und Tod
Um also die Schönheit von Kompromissen zu vermitteln,
müssen Sie den Menschen nur sagen, dass das
Leben aus Kompromissen besteht, nur der Tod ist
kompromisslos  sein Finale, sein absoluter
Tod, ein Fanatiker, ein wandelndes
Ausrufezeichen, keine Argumente, keine
Standpunkte, es ist nur der Tod, aber  Das Leben ist
voller Kompromisse. Behalte dieses sprudelnde Eisen hier,
noch besser nach dem Schlafen. Behalte diesen Ratschlag
für Fusee. Jahr. Van Buren. Ja, wenn
jemand mich in einen Sklaven verwandeln will,
werde ich
kämpfen  Frechheit, was könnte jemand
versuchen, die nächste Person auf der
Straße zu töten oder die nächste Person auf der Straße zu vergewaltigen.
Ich werde den Arm nehmen und
kämpfen, und ich habe das zweimal in meinem Leben getan,
es tut mir sehr leid, aber ich  Ich schäme mich nicht
dafür. Ich werde dasselbe tun, wenn dein
Leben in der nächsten Minute in unmittelbarer Gefahr wäre
und ich dich durch Kämpfen retten könnte.
Ich werde kämpfen und ich werde
kämpfen, wenn jemand versucht, mich in einen Sklaven zu verwandeln,
aber sonst nichts  nicht
für sogenannte nationale Interessen oder heilige
Stätten kämpfen, ich werde nicht für ein zusätzliches
Schlafzimmer für meine Nation kämpfen, nicht nur für mein
Leben, für das Leben der nächsten Person und
für meine Freiheit, sonst nichts, die
sogar geheimen Lieder auf den Einladungen von
Creegan Mitka  Lager ist extatisch Cr  eek
nippte an einem Stock an Jom Kippur klickte
auf Afton Golan, der und Ryans Ipsus der
heißeste Fleischfresser war Gimmick war
erfolgreich eine Farm in Creek Sue's Ich bin
wahrscheinlich die schlimmste Erfahrung, die ich je
in meinem Leben gemacht habe, und ich glaube nicht, dass ich das zusammenfassen kann
Es ist in ein paar Worten in einem
Fernsehinterview zu schwer, jemandem zu erklären, der
nicht auf dem
Schlachtfeld ist,
wie schrecklich das Bedford-Bärenschlachtfeld
ist, aber wie gesagt,
wenn ich die Aggression mit Gewalt stoppen müsste,
werde ich sie mit Gewalt stoppen  Der Unterschied zwischen
Friedensaktivisten wie mir und einem
prinzipientreuen Pazifisten wie vielen Europäern
besteht darin, dass für einen Pazifisten das ultimative
Übel Kriegsgewalt ist. Nein, für mich
ist Aggression das ultimative Übel, und
manchmal muss Aggression
mit Gewalt gestoppt werden
ein Ergebnis von Aggression
Aggression ist die Sache aller Kriege,
Saddam Hussein zu nennen, also ist für mich der böse
Rivale meines Lebens kein Schlachtfeld,
es ist die Aggression, die passiert
r wird
nicht mit Messern gedacht. Ich weiß nicht. Ich
kann diese Frage nicht beantworten, weil ich
nicht sicher bin, ob ich niemanden auf kurze Distanz getötet habe,
aber jemals habe ich anderen mit meinen
Waffen Verletzungen oder den Tod zugefügt, die
ich nicht verdammen kann  Schreien Sie
sogar theoretisieren, lassen Sie mich auf die
Wangenzellen schlagen, nette Notiz, Barton Creek
Co-op, jetzt in Großbritannien, und Eisen
vermissen genetisch Katya Bashir, ein Muta-Gefährte, der
seinen Reichtum
ermöglicht  eine Zeit großer
Verzweiflung, weil ich das Gefühl hatte, wenn meine Mutter
sich umgebracht
hätte, bedeutet das, dass sie mich nicht geliebt hat, wenn
sie mich geliebt hätte, wäre sie geblieben, wenn
sie mich nicht geliebt hätte, niemand wird mich jemals lieben
, wenn selbst meine Mutter es könnte.  Ich liebe mich nicht
Ich bin es nicht wert, von irgendjemandem geliebt zu werden, also
hasste ich die Haare dafür, dass sie sich umgebracht hatte, als wäre
sie mit einem Liebhaber durchgebrannt
was aber ich nehme an, dass
wenn  Dass seine Frau sich umgebracht hat,
muss etwas Schreckliches an ihm sein, und
mehr als alles andere hasste ich mich selbst,
weil ich dachte, wenn ich ein braver kleiner
Junge wäre, hätte meine Mutter mich geliebt und
wäre geblieben, es hat
sehr lange gedauert, bis ich mich wieder erholt habe  Es ist an der Zeit
, Wut, Einsamkeit und Verzweiflung zu beseitigen
und sie durch Neugier,
Mitgefühl, Empathie und Menschlichkeit zu ersetzen. Als ich
endlich dazu kam, über meine Familie in
einem Buch mit dem Titel „Eine Geschichte von Liebe und
Dunkelheit“ zu schreiben, werden Sie nicht ein Gramm
Bitterkeit, Wut oder Hass
finden  Mitgefühl, mehr Neugier und
Empathie, und ich habe dieses Buch geschrieben,
um die Grenze zwischen Komödie und
Tragödie aufzuheben. Komödie und Tragödie sind nicht zwei
verschiedene Planeten, sondern nur zwei verschiedene
Fenster, durch die wir
dieselbe Landschaft unseres Lebens sehen können, die
eine düstere Entscheidung unterstützt  zu entriegeln
Bedingungen mit seinem entfernteren auf der Gesellschaft
Raymundo Reise sogar die Etiketten kashish
sie ok jetzt dieses Zimmer Waffel melancholisch
wir sind voreingenommen in der Luft, während ich auf s liege  ip
Ich bin Harry, jetzt der Saddam, es hat
in zwei
Häusern in einem Kibbutz in einer beliebigen Sprache eine
gemeinsame und interessierte Mikwe
fertig gestellt, die das dunkelste Holz auf einem 70.000 Pfandrecht härtet, das
wir von der Größe entwickelt haben, und ich habe
gegen meine rebelliert  Vater, ich verließ mein Zuhause,
weil ich alles werden wollte, was
er nicht war, und ich wollte nichts werden,
was er war, er war ein rechter
Intellektueller,
ein Schriftsteller, und ich entschied mich, ein
linker sozialdemokratischer Traktorfahrer zu werden,
er war ein kleiner Mann  Ich beschloss,
sehr groß zu werden, er arbeitete nicht für mich, also
wollte ich das Gegenteil von dem sein, was er war,
aber dann lebe ich 30 Jahre an diesen
Gemeinschaftstischen, und neben vielen anderen
Dingen war dies für mich die beste
Universität für die menschliche Natur  in jenen
jahren in einem kibbuz, der ein bisschen
wie eine
großfamilie ist keine geheimnisse fast keine geheimnisse jeder weiß fast
alles nah jeder
dafif armacost ist a cappella etwa 400
leute männer frauen und kinder kleines
dorf aber keine geheimnisse
ich  Ich wusste alles über sie, einschließlich der
intimsten Besuche. Die Strafe war, dass
sie viel mehr über mich wussten, als ich
wollte, dass sie es über mich wissen, aber das
war ein fairer Deal, und für einen Schriftsteller ist dies
eine wunderbare Vorbereitung und wunderbare
Ausbildung, die ich gesehen habe  Menschen in den besten
und schlimmsten Zeiten habe ich gesehen, wie sie
gezeugt werden wollen und wie sie
nicht gezeugt werden wollen. Ich kannte sie
in- und auswendig, und ich bin sehr dankbar für
diese jahrelange Kibbles-Erfahrung, dass
sie mich zu dem gemacht haben  Schriftsteller, der ich
als Wurstreden-Streicharzt bin, landete in einem
Chaba-Gillies im Meer, lockte einen Mann,
der nur von neuem fehlschlug, unterzeichnete wenige da
Noya, die ich kenne
, eine Menge ernster Künstler, um einige Etiketten zu ärgern, ein beurre
manié willen, zitierte Sarkozy ja  Ein großes Versagen
war von jenen finanzierenden Vätern und
Müttern, die naiv, fast kindisch waren,
anzunehmen, dass sie die
menschliche Natur in einer
Generation verändern können, indem sie die Umstände ändern, an die
ich immer noch glaube, an die Veränderung der Gesellschaft, an die ich
immer noch glaube  sozialdemokratische Idee,
aber ich glaube nicht mehr daran,
die menschliche Natur zu revolutionieren. Ich
halte das für ein gefährliches Konzept. Ich denke, dass viele
Idealisten, die glauben, dass sie
eine Gesellschaft schaffen können, die einen
neuen Mann oder eine neue Frau hervorbringt, sehr gefährlich sind,
denn sehr oft fangen sie an, wenn sie
scheitern  sie fangen an,
Druck auszuüben, und dann ist der Weg kurz zur
Unterdrückung und der Weg ist kurz zur
Verfolgung, das hat es in der
Kibbutz-Bewegung nie gegeben, keine Unterdrückung, keine
Verfolgung, aber Enttäuschung, die menschliche
Natur ändert sich nicht, nicht in ein oder zwei
Generationen  Tiere
auf dem Grundstück und auf unserem Meer krank zu sein
Serben und nein in Arnheim Kiki sogar
von Klausner zu uns zu unserer großartigsten
ah temperamentvollen Handwerksstämme Biome Dissin
Armee Meine Schwester Zeichen Volt würde
sich auch als Wolke entwickeln und Wissenschaft dunkel sehen,
nein, ich war  überhaupt nicht stark Ich war
vierzehneinhalb Jahre alt
Ich verließ mein Zuhause Ich zog an einen
unbekannten Ort, wo ich niemanden kannte und
niemand mich kannte, den ich brauchte  viel
Kraft und Mut, also habe ich es in meinen Namen gesteckt.
Ich hatte es nicht in meinem Herzen, also
wollte ich es zumindest in meinem Namen haben.
Das war das, was ich mehr als
alles andere brauchte, als ich von zu Hause wegging und dorthin
ging  lebe in einem kibbuz es ist nur ein
amisch aus manaus es war das eine neue es ende
es aß gut nein nein ich glaube nicht, dass der name
mich verändert hat es repräsentierte nur eine
bestimmte reihe von prioritäten in meinem leben ich habe es
sogar während meiner jahre in der versucht  Selbst
in meiner politischen Tätigkeit und sicherlich
in meinem Schreiben habe ich versucht, mutig zu sein
in dem einfachen Sinne, dass ich
nicht unbedingt dieser oder jener
Mehrheit entsprechen muss, nicht immer versuchen, beliebt zu sein,
nicht einmal besorgt darüber bin,
unter meinen eigenen Leuten sehr unbeliebt zu sein
die Art von Mut, an die ich
als 14-jähriger Junge geglaubt habe, an die ich heute noch
glaube, Alice ist unschuldig, eine Stimmung,
nachdem Anna mein Nein auf den
gequälten Akmal Alpharetta zu Kelton in
der AG Narayan verzehrt haben will
Atsugi
der Schwere  Ministerium, in dem wir uns verklagt haben
, und deshalb interessierte sich Mustafa
Saunders für einen traditionelleren Begriffskonflikt,
einen Hauskonflikt, und alles in Ordnung,
als Israel das ICCPR abfeuerte, eine Panik, die
ich anfangen würde, weiterzumachen und die
Res zu füttern. iDVD Palästinenser Axt ist Dustin Akbar
die Katastrophe  Visa sind 700.000
Palästinenser und Palästinenser ein Muslim auf der
Flucht würde sich nicht in Musselin zurückziehen
Irland Geschwindigkeit die Einheiten neben ein paar
Millionen auf Diamanten die Menge dieses
Rätsels und ihm geben ist noch nicht der
palästinensische Fernsehfilm ein murrainer unverheirateter
Chesser auf der Hamdi in Haifa  oft
auf Independent-Filmfestivals
[Musik]
wie weit ist Anders Mutter Eva so ehrlich
in Israel erfreut besucht Liam oder
Durga Trent liebe Mission ist - of
America mr.  Statton auf st.  Paul Center
Pavelka Häuser und Palästinenser Amit ist
ihr Olympus Ich bin Olympia Organisatoren des Iran
Khodro Täter – Unabhängiges Filmfestival,
also wird dieser Murmeltier-Anime-
Animationsgeschwindigkeitsfilm für eine
Nettomiete mit Anne-Marie Jessas neuem
Film aufgedreht, der Mia für Oscars verehrt Augen, die nicht
an Festivals teilnehmen  Das unbeleuchtete Kino Dubai Mar del
Plata in Locarno wird
einen Film gesehen, in dem viele Recht haben, aber
ich meine, die Palästinenser und Nazareth
haben die israelische Staatsbürgerschaft, aber sie sind
Bürger dritter Klasse, sie bekommen nicht die
gleichen Rechte, die sie nicht haben, die sie
dort haben  mehr als 50 Gesetze, die
offizielle israelische Gesetze ablehnen, die sie
diskriminieren, die
ihnen sogar sagen, wen sie heiraten können und wen
sie nicht heiraten können. Jemand aus Nazareth
kann nicht legal jemanden
aus Bethlehem
heiraten
nach Gaza
können nicht legal in Ramallah leben. Ich meine,
es gibt alle möglichen Regeln, nach denen
sie spielen müssen, bei denen es nur um
ke geht  Palästinenser voneinander zu
trennen, die ganze Idee dahinter ist, den Palästinensern zu sagen, dass
Sie kein Palästinenser sind, Sie
sind ein israelischer Staatsbürger, Sie sind ein
Westjordanland oder Sie sind ein Gaza-In Ihrem Jerusalem.
Ich werde einen Ausweis mit verschiedenen
Farben und verschiedenen Nummern haben und es ist
Alles Teil eines Systems der Apartheid und
Trennung, ein weiterer Jessilee Toyota in
Haifa in Israel, die Scans in Wadi und eine
von Kovacs besessene OS America Nation-Geldbörse
ist einfach ähem Baretta normalerweise
in schrecklich verarmter Mahwah, der
östlichen Hochelfe in Palästina,
Yahooza LEM aus Bethlehem  Trent Ich kenne den
Beruf seit meiner Geburt und ich
habe Eltern, die mir keine Politik
aufgedrängt haben, mit denen sie nie über Politik gesprochen haben,
aber wir haben gesehen, was passiert ist, wir
mussten durch die Kontrollpunkte, wir mussten
an der Grenze angehalten werden,
wir  musste einer Leibesvisitation unterzogen werden, wie ich es
verstanden habe, ohne dass meine Eltern jemals
etwas gesagt hätten, dass wir anders seien
als andere Menschen, dass wir anders behandelt würden
Veranda des Hauses und in
Bethlehem die Treppe vorne
und alle sieben Minuten fuhr ein
Militärjeep vorbei, wir zählten
die Jeeps und die Jeeps, die
man nicht sammeln konnte, als ich
jünger war, dort war es nach israelischem
Gesetz illegal  Dass mehr als 10 Leute 10
Leute zusammenkommen müssen, also wenn wir früher mit der
Familie Mittag- oder Abendessen hatten, gingen die Leute
zu zweit oder zu dritt, wir
würden nicht alle zum
Haus meiner Großmutter zurückgehen wollen, zum Beispiel im Unterricht,
aber rohe amerikanische Biotik Alicia  Sag
es zu Hause und jedes Gericht danach, aber
das reicht aus und wieder wird das
Zuhause los. Unsere Lösung ist sehr
einfach. Eine Stadt, eine Stadt, ein Staat für
alle Menschen, die
sich darum kümmern  bist muslimisch
jüdisch christlich buddhistisch atheist was
du zum frühstück isst es geht
mich nichts an es geht einen staat nichts an
diese dinge gehen niemanden etwas an es ist
eine private
angelegenheit Palästina war das Palest  ine war ein
multiethnischer multireligiöser Ort
Palästina mein Vater wurde dort geboren er
wurde vor 48 geboren war das Muslime Juden und
Christen lebten heute in Palästina
Israel ist das ist ein jüdischer Staat du
hast Rechte wenn du jüdisch bist und wenn
du  Bist du kein Jude, du bist Christ oder
du bist Muslim? Auf Wiedersehen oder du lebst als
Sklave, das ist die Realität des Lebens hier
und das ist für die Zukunft nicht
machbar  Falke das Wasser auf c4 Initiative Ich habe
wieder mit
Ionen angefangen Nachteile es ist eine Perspektive und
in 50 nicht 40 Ich verstehe die s stimme zu nein
weil ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendeinen Sinn hat
, sagen wir mal die Deutschen 1945
und die Polen sofort zu nehmen  nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg und sagen wir machen
euch beide eine nation gelbe busse
integration warum polen warum
deutschland gleich eine nation wird
natürlich wäre das eine wahnsinnige idee gewesen zu
viel wut böses blut frustration
frustration mangel
Vertrauensstufe eins zwischen Israelis und
Palästinensern hoffte auf eine friedliche
Aufteilung des Landes in die Heimat, also
verstehe ich das Ein-Staat-Ideal auf eine
Weise, die ich noch radikaler bin als
diese Künstler. Ich glaube an eine niederstaatliche
Welt, ich meine die alte  Nationalstaat
am Ende, aber solange jede
Nation,
ob diese Nation Schweiz oder
Irak genannt wird, jede Nation Bass an
ihren Fenstern und Schlösser an den Türen hat,
muss das jüdische Volk dasselbe haben, was wir
versucht haben  Jahrtausende ohne leben
wir waren die einzigen die kein
eigenes Land hatten keine Gitter an unseren Fenstern
keine Schlösser an unseren Türen keine Armee keine Waffen
dies endete mancherorts tragisch für die Juden
manches Publikum klatscht
Bravo vielerorts  Sie haben faule Eier geworfen
und an noch mehr Orten haben sie
den Ecto geschlachtet. Wir haben eine Ein-Personen-
Existenzshow gegeben, ohne den Staat, es hat nicht
funktioniert, also werden wir das nächste Mal
nach den anderen auf die Party gehen, wir gehen nicht  g Um
die ersten zu sein, wir israelischen Juden,
werden wir nicht die ersten in der
Nachbarschaft sein, die unsere Verteidigung herunterwinken
und sagen, lasst uns Liebe machen, nicht Krieg,
wir warten auf andere, wir werden der Party beitreten,
wir werden sie zur Abwechslung nicht starten,
weil  wir haben die Partei vor
Tausenden von Jahren gegründet und niemand ist ihr beigetreten. Ja,
ich glaube, solange jede
Nation eine Heimat hat, brauchen die Juden auch eine.
Wenn ich Heimat sage, bedeutet das nicht
ausschließlich jüdisch, es bedeutet nicht, dass es keine
Minderheiten gibt
bedeutet nicht keine gleichen Menschenrechte, sondern im
Gegensatz dazu gleiche Rechte für
Minderheiten, aber ich meine einen Teil des
Territoriums, einen Teil des historischen Palästina, einen
Teil des Landes, in dem das jüdische Volk
zur Abwechslung einmal das Recht hat, eine
Mehrheit und nicht eine Minderheit zu sein
Ausdruck achtern ist eine Klammer ein Gemüse auf
dieser Macht von Dean Ornish Türkisch, das
ist Statistik des Judentums Typ 120. Erstens
habe ich viele
Jahre lang für das Recht des palästinensischen
Volkes gekämpft, einen eigenen
Heimatstaat in Pa zu haben  Lestine und dass die
Palästinenser die Wahl haben, entweder als
Teil der palästinensischen Mehrheit im
Staat Palästina oder als Teil der
palästinensischen Minderheit im Staat
Israel zu leben, ist dies eine anständige Wahl, die ich
meinen palästinensischen Kollegen anbiete,
es wird zwei geben  Heimatländer Sie können
in Ihrem eigenen nationalen Heimatland leben, wenn
Sie dies bevorzugen, oder Sie können
als Vollbürger in einem nahe gelegenen Land leben,
aber Ihre nationale Adresse wird
in Ihrem eigenen Land erfüllt
Schlinge war Mohanji-
Fäustling ist Hydratationssamen fehlt der
Aufzug ungesehen eine Schwester Venus das Stutfohlen
Praktizierende im Übergang viele
praktische Probleme, aber glauben Sie mir, dies
sind Lebensprobleme, keine Todesprobleme. Das
Zuhause zu verlieren ist eine schreckliche Tragödie, aber
es ist nichts anderes, als das Leben
zu verlieren  Millionen Mal,
anstatt eines meiner Kinder zu verlieren
, sollten verlorene Häuser durch neue Häuser ersetzt werden,
verlorene Jobs sollten durch neue Jo ersetzt werden  bs
sollte dies ein Projekt der arabischen
Welt, der internationalen Gemeinschaft und
Israels sein, das den palästinensischen
Flüchtlingen ein Zuhause und Arbeitsplätze bietet, da einige von den
israelischen Siedlern im Westjordanland
nach
Israel zurückkehren müssen, weil sie zufällig
privat sitzen  -besessenes arabisches Land andere
dürfen als Bürger oder ständige
Einwohner im zukünftigen Staat
Palästina bleiben, aber nicht als Herren, als Bürger
oder als Wohnsitz, nicht als Herren, das ist
kompliziert, aber nicht rückgängig zu machen, glauben Sie mir, das
alles ist millionenfach einfacher
als  Einen Krieg zu führen, ist viel einfacher,
weil dies eine schmerzhafte Lösung sein wird,
aber niemand wird sterben, die letzten Einschnitte in seine
Einlässe, den ganzen Schreibtisch, jede Seite, der
Ehrgeiz hier, Analphabeten oder Unterdrückung
Muster für das Ende
nach Jesus Paul hier Judas und C's
sehen keine Leute, die sie dachte, als Judas
Disick ist ein durchtriebener Seufzer, also war ich es, also
appellierte Ian als Anti-  Semitismus greift eine
Superkuh an
30 Menschen betrachten einen Herumlungernden ja,
aber lassen Sie mich zunächst klarstellen, dass der
Roman Judas kein Manifest über
Juden oder Antisemitismus oder Christentum ist, sondern
ein Roman, es ist eine Geschichte über drei
sehr unterschiedliche Personen, die in  Am
Anfang des Romans sind völlig
Fremde sogar potenzielle Feinde und
am Ende der Geschichte
lieben sie sich fast. Sie werden
wie eine Familie.
Dies ist der Kern des Romans. Im
Hintergrund geht
es um
Verrat und Loyalität
biblische Figur des Judas, der
in der christlichen Tradition als der
archetypische Verbrecher, der teuflische
Verräter und in vielen christlichen Kreisen
auch mit dem unzuverlässigen Juden identifiziert wird, der
klug, klug und geldgierig ist und bereit ist
, jeden, sogar seinen Herrn und seinen
Gott, für dreißig Silberlinge zu verkaufen
Protagonist hier als
Tschernobyl des christlichen Antisemitismus definiert, in
dem Roman gibt es eine völlig andere
Vorstellung von Judas Judas is pres  in diesem
Romanautor als jemand, der
noch mehr an Jesus glaubt als Jesus an sich
selbst, glaubt er, dass
er eine Kreuzigung für Jesus bereitstellen muss
, um die Augen der ganzen Welt zu öffnen, damit sie
das Licht sehen,
mit anderen Worten Kreuzigung und dann
Erlösung Kreuzigung  Der Weg zum
Himmelreich nun also Judas in diesem
Roman er macht sich keines Verrats schuldig er macht
sich des Fanatismus schuldig er will Erlösung
jetzt vollkommene Erlösung und wie viele
Fanatiker opfert er seinen
geliebten Lehrermeister Gott Jesus Christus nicht
weil er das Geld will sondern  weil
er zuerst sofortige Erlösung für mein Land will,
und wenn diese Alternative ein Spielzeug
ist, wird eine Alternative so interpretiert, dass
der eiserne Protagonist Nirenberg für wie
als Erfolg
tan Hetty de velde Tresorbild und Azov-
Schisma-Familien auf Bondi bekannt gegeben wurde, verdammt noch mal,
oder die Krawatte durchhängen  verurteilte, schwelgende
Freundin und jede Spielzeugzunge und
Dolmetscherin, sie besitzt ein Auto, und ich weiß nicht
, ob Interpretationen die Welt verändern
können  Ich kann es nicht beweisen,
aber ich habe diese Interpretation
auf verführerische Weise präsentiert. Ich möchte versuchen, die
Menschen dazu zu verführen, die Dinge
ganz anders zu sehen als das,
was ihnen als
kleine Kinder gesagt wurde oder was ihnen
in der Schule beigebracht wurde. Versuchen Sie, dieselbe Geschichte zu
durchschauen  Eine andere Perspektive Ich
ermutige meinen Leser, ein wenig
Detektiv zu sein und sich zu fragen, ob es
vielleicht eine bessere Erklärung für
die Motive dieses teuflischen Judas gibt,
vielleicht bringe ich meinen Leser sogar dazu,
sich einige Fragen über sich selbst zu stellen
, nicht nur über die  Bibel nicht
nur über Jerusalem, nicht nur über die
Kreuzigung oder den berühmtesten Fall der
Geschichte, sondern über sich selbst. Hören wir uns
die Luftverschmutzung an. Ein zweites
Meeresbild  Nur eine gerichtliche Zwei-Konten-
Zentralpraxis ist ein Knopfdruck von Tour
d'Azyrs Versuch, das Kaliumspielzeug zu treffen, um
zur Vernunft zu kommen  Fahrzeug zu einem
Chirurgen siehe nach Spanisch eine hartnäckige
spezifische Sie haben gerade diese
zusätzliche Arbeit in Betracht gezogen sind gut Wenn ich es auf
den Punkt bringen muss, würde ich sagen, dass
wir eine Zivilisation des Zweifels und der
Argumentation sind, schwierige Fragen stellen, niemals
etwas nehmen  Zugegeben,
es ist nicht umsonst, dass die Juden
nie einen Papst hatten, noch könnten sie einen Papst haben, wenn sich
jemals jemand nennt, oder vielleicht wird er
selbst der Papst der Juden sein, jeder Jude wird
auf diesen Papst zugehen und sagen, hör mir zu,
fünf Minuten werde ich sagen  Sie ein
für alle Mal,
was Gott wirklich von uns will, ich
weiß es besser, es ist ein gewisses unkünstlerisches
Gen, ein spirituelles Anarchistikum, das
die Juden seit Tausenden von
Jahren begleitet,
kein Wunder, dass viele, viele große Juden in der
Geschichte
Abraham Moses und Jesus
Freuds und  Kafka und Spinoza und Karl
Marx und Einstein, sie haben
in ihren Biografien eines gemeinsam:
eine jugendliche Rebellion gegen eine sehr
mächtige
Vaterfigur  Umfassende Erklärung, aber das ist
das Geheimnis der hartnäckigen Langlebigkeit
der jüdischen Zivilisation.
Fragen sind nie
selbstverständlich. Als ich ein kleiner Junge war, fragte ich
meinen Vater, warum wir
Juden eine Frage immer mit einer
Frage beantworten,
und mein Vater sagte  warum nicht das
ist mein lustiger Tag das ist unsere Geschichte das
ist hey Alisha sang Z s ki Tov anak
im Himalaya-Buch Wissenschaft hält
Stimpy Form von Sensibilität fest,
dass ich geistig tot bin,
fühlte das Haus zu ein bisschen
dumm a  melancholie die schwestern müssen
eine riesige dimension spüren flut ein wenig
estas das ist paris auf unserer edition ist
melancholie war meins 0 meter gut glücklich
melancholie findet man in der
kunst vieler jüdischer künstler, ob
sie musiker oder komödianten wie woody allen
oder  Schriftsteller wie Kafka die Idee,
dass Komödie und Tragödie keine
unterschiedlichen Planeten sind, sie sind nur
verschiedene Perspektiven auf dieselbe
Realität die Idee, dass Freude und
Traurigkeit keine e sind  Unter der Bedingung
können sie gemischt werden und die Mischung kann sehr
kreativ werden sehr bereichernd sehr eine sehr
erstklassige Nahrung für die Seele die
Mischung aus Melancholie und Freude und
Unsicherheit Optimismus und Pessimismus
Sensibilität für die Leiden
anderer und gleichzeitig Gewissheit
Selbstgerechtigkeit diese seltsame Mischung
eine seltsame Kombination es sorgt nicht
für einen leichten Alltag in der jüdischen
Gesellschaft aber ich finde es spannend und
ich mag es auch in Zeiten, in denen es mir
schwer fällt zu überleben wie halte ich es
noch aus  mag es, wenn sie diese Seite rockt,
sobald sie in der Mann-Disco-
Behandlung leichter Sie hinter auf
Keynesian feiern, auf langem Blinken eines polierten
Spiegels, dort über Israel, Sie würden die
meisten dieser
Gründung Israel-Zeit vollständig unterschreiben und dann sehen, was für
einen Bus-Notfall sie erhalten sollten
Informationen zu Ihrem eigenen Zustandsende.
Oh, ich werde diese Frage sofort beantworten,
aber denken Sie daran,
dass sie niemals zwei Israelis dazu bringen sollten, sich
gegenseitig zuzustimmen  andere worüber Israel wir wollen
, dass ein Israeli mit sich
selbst
einer Meinung ist, jeder ist ambivalent, jeder hat einen
gespaltenen Geist und eine gespaltene Seele. Ich möchte ein
Stück mit den Nachbarn sein. Eine
pluralistische Gesellschaft sein
Land als Open-Air-Seminar Wenn Sie wollen, eine
Nation mit neun Millionen Bürgern, Juden und
Arabern, neun Millionen Ministerpräsidenten, neun
Millionen Propheten und Messias. Ich mag es,
Israel  ein Land, es ist keine Nation, es ist
eine feurige Ansammlung von Argumenten. Ich fühle auch,
dass Erbe und Outfit ein seltsamer
Ort sind. Danke
[Musik],
sehr gut, danke